de gel. Olivier Bachand.
- Les travailleurs sont
au rendez-vous et les fraises
aussi. La saison s'annonce
bonne chez Bélisle, un des plus
grands producteurs au Québec.
LOUIS BÉLISLE, Associ. des prod.
fraises et framboises du Québec
- Avec la chaleur qu'on a eue
puis on n'a pas eu gros d'eau,
la fraise vient pas
gorgée d'eau. Vraiment,
le taux de sucre est très,
très élevé dans nos fruits puis
c'est succulent comme c'est là.
- Grâce au temps chaud,
ce printemps, la croissance
des fraises est en avance
de deux semaines sur
le calendrier régulier.
Mais une fois les fleurs
sorties, c'est un casse-tête
si le mercure descend sous zéro.
Si elles gèlent,
il n'y aura pas de fruit.
- On a un système par aspersion.
- Depuis le début de l'année,
Louis Bélisle a dû arroser
ses champs une dizaine de fois
pour garder ses fraises en vie.
- Les producteurs au Québec,
ce printemps, ils ont travaillé
terriblement fort pour sauver
leurs fleurs parce qu'à toutes
les fois qu'il y a du gel, faut
que t'arroses toute la nuit,
faut que tes étangs fournissent.
- On estime que les pertes
causées par le gel sont
de moins de 10 % à
l'échelle de la province.
- On n'aura pas une année comme
l'année passée qu'on manquait
de fruits puis tout le kit.
Cette année, on tombe
dans une année normale.
- Ici aussi, on voit une belle
grappe qui a déjà commencé
à être formée.
- Ceux qui n'ont pas
de système d'irrigation,
comme le producteur de bleuets
Raphaël Gaucher, sont
plus vulnérables. Ses plants
ont été victimes du gel,
mais rien de trop dramatique.
RAPHAËL GAUCHER, propriétaire,
Bleuetière Le Rêve bleu
- On quantifie ça à peu près
de 5 à 10 % selon les régions
dans le champ. On a eu
des pertes qui sont assez
minimes comparativement
à d'autres producteurs.
- Au Saguenay-Lac-Saint-Jean,
par exemple, les producteurs
envisagent des pertes
de 25 à 75 % en raison du gel.
Certains ont aussi été
durement touchés en Estrie.
- Dans Lanaudière,
Gaétan Beaulieu a dû partir
ses gicleurs une fois
cette saison pour protéger
ses bleuets contre le gel.
GAÉTAN BEAULIEU, propriétaire,
Bleuetière G. Beaulieu
- Là, il est survenu un froid
pas mal sévère la semaine
passée. Et je vous dirais que
je pense que je m'en suis sorti
très bien parce que je regarde
mes bleuets, il y a pratiquement
pas de dommages dû à
l'irrigation que j'ai faite.
- Il s'attend à une bonne
récolte cette année.
- Mais vous savez, dans
l'agriculture, c'est très bon
aujourd'hui, mais s'il arrive
une grêle au moins de juillet,
il y a plus rien.
Alors, c'est difficile
à faire des prédictions.
- Dans ce métier,
c'est presque toujours
la météo qui a le dernier mot.
Ici Olivier Bachand,